Film Courage: Is there a specific structure
you use or prefer for writing scripts?
Shawn Christensen, co-writer/director of The
Vanishing of Sidney Hall movie: Well it depends
on the script.
For example, right now I started writing a
screenplay (I just started writing a screenplay)
based on true life stories.
This is my second one I’m in right now and
it’s a whole different experience than the
other stuff I did which was just original
material.
I prefer writing the true story or the stuff
based on real-life stuff because frankly the
people’s stories are better than my imagination.
Some of their own stories of what has happened
is better than what I would make up.
And in those cases I have to do a lot of research
and adapt.
So adapting a script and an original script
are two different things.
For an original screenplay I usually start
with the characters and let them talk to each
other and I kind of have an idea of the plot.
I don’t outline.
I just let the characters infer the plot.
Like I know the concept and I know the overall
beginning, middle and end and I let the characters
decide how we get from the middle and the
end, let them bounce off of each other like
improvising and then build around that.
But for adapting you can’t really do that
so you kind of have to gather all of the facts
and do all of the research and then it’s
honestly something I’m learning to be honest.
I really just kind of writing out all of the
things (the great moments) in this particular
script I’m writing and then knowing that
I’m going to cut half of them out.
But just really I write them out because they
are fun, they’re great, they are interesting
to me and then when I find out they are not
interesting to anyone else, I’ll give it
to 10 key people and I’ll see what is the
consensus of what is working and what is not.
Is the screenplay slow?
Which character is not needed?
Can I take two characters and combine them?
I’ll do that stuff until I give it to my
inner circle of people who I think are smart
and trust.
Bouncing a screenplay is very important (off
of people) and I feel I have the ability to
do that.